christmas has come early Sabrina fans
the trailer for mid Winter's Tale is
here and I've got you covered with all
the hidden details on what me might
expect in this episode now I hate to be
a Grinch but my guess is that this
episode won't have any huge you know
reveals or big twists that will affect
part two since it's more of an add-on to
the series it'll be more of a contained
episode that will likely revolve around
Sabrina and the gang taking on some
magical force and this trailer is
chock-full of little goodies so hang up
your stockings and sit on Santa's lap
let's break this baby down we start on
the familiar welcome to Greendale sign
as some fake CGI snow falls while we're
introduced to Santa and these creepy
mannequin elves check out the lineup for
Santa and you'll see everyone is dressed
in 1950s 60s period clothing which leads
me to believe this is a flashback
perhaps hinting at the origin of the
demonic force in this episode now it's
possible this could be present-day since
the show does have that old 50s 60s
aesthetic but I'm leaning more towards
flashback we then get a brief glimpse of
somewhere we haven't seen before it
looks like some sort of lounge for adult
warlocks you'll notice no females here
Sabrina wishes the weird sisters a happy
solstice since witches don't celebrate
Christmas they celebrate the winter
solstice a time to mark when the days
begin to get longer and who can forget
this creepy blinking elf
we catch a quick glimpse of Zelda hilda
and Salem before seeing the Spellman's
house covered in snow I think it looks
pretty cool and bonus points if you
noticed the pentagram in the middle of
the wreath
Sabrina stands over a fireplace and even
though Zelda Hilda Ambrose and her are
there I'm not super convinced this is
the Spellman's home notice the name
Leticia on the stocking and the Santa
and the photo who looks similar to the
one we saw earlier this is either an
attempt to lure Santa or ward him off
and Santa seems pretty evil since he
uses his sack to grab someone a sack
Ambrose is hard at work researching when
we get a glimpse of what appears to be
the main demon in this episode a woman
in white almost as if she's a ghost of
Christmas past however I'm not convinced
she's an evil force Sabrina and the
weird sisters perform a ritual with a
white dress could it be the same dress
the ghost here is wearing are they
wanting to communicate with her we then
get this really creepy demon who
appears to have trapped Susie is that
Susie guys let me know what you think in
the comments
cute Sabrina gets Harvey a present so
it's good to know they aren't exactly on
bad terms and this person looks like
they've seen better days acting as a
real-life Lumiere Oh TV Wardwell has
created a gingerbread Spellman house
with Ambrose Zelda hilda and Sabrina all
being little gingerbread men which she
promptly bites off knowing war dwells
history with creating voodoo type
figures I wonder if that will come into
play and here is what I think is the
most important clip of the trailer
Sabrina's father handing over a baby to
the Dark Lord this is an obvious
flashback but we aren't sure if this is
Sabrina or the twin we saw in part 1 of
the series it could also be the moment
when Sabrina's father signs her name in
the book of the Beast on her behalf
Hilda protects herself with a rolling
pin as a bunch of knives fall around her
and Ambrose has creepy ghost girls sneak
up on him again I don't think she's that
evil but is perhaps wanting the
Spellman's hell and the trailer ends
with Sabrina giving a Cheers likely
after saving the day my main thoughts
are that the Santa is the main villain
and he's possessed by this demon here
and this ghost lady was maybe a victim
of him in the past and they need her
help to stop him I hope you're as
excited for this episode as I am I want
to know what you guys think and if I
missed anything I'll be doing a full
breakdown of this episode hopefully
coming out with it on the 15th so make
sure you're subscribed with the Belle on
and smash that like button in the mean
time I'm wishing you a happy solstice
and remember daddy loves you very much